that's uh
it had to happen
so i expect that when i give a talk in
chicago but oh no
that's just a different kind of food i
think out there in chicago it's not the
same
so i i've given a
talk similar to this um a couple of
times before the first time it um it
threatened to go on for about two hours
and i've since learned how to be a
little bit more efficient i really will
try to keep this about to an hour
on the other hand i think it's um i
think it's great for people to be able
to ask questions
uh so please do i need to get closer to
the mic yeah i will do my best
so please do stop me and ask questions
and i'll just try to do the best i can
with the time that i have and i'd be
happy to speak with some of you later
but i will
it just became a 45 minute talk so i
will try to do what i'm going to do in
about 45 minutes and then if there's
questions i'll
speak about whatever people would like
me to speak about or we can make it
informal over drinks fair enough
so
i'm going to cover
a couple of things really superficially
because i expect a lot of you have seen
some of this before but i think it's
helpful to set a context here
before dealing with some of the more
advanced topics and the the two main
ones that i'd like to cover would be a
fast r web package coming from simon
urbanic down at at t and the other one
being rstudio's shiny package
but i'd just like to give you a little
bit of context there and this is
probably a review for some of you
but
just for starters let's say hello world
a couple of different ways and so this
is a quick detour through maybe the
history of the web and i realized that a
couple of us here saw the web evolved
but a lot of you were far too young to
see the beginning so maybe you'll learn
something along the way
so i'm working here on a mac and i'll do
something both here on the mac and then
log in remotely to a linux server back
at yale right now i'm just doing
something locally here on on this
machine i happen to have a web server
installed it might be apache the mac
puts things in funny places i don't
entirely approve of this but we'll live
with it there's a two places here i want
to i want to look at i'll go into
documents first
and then in the documents folder i have
this
little file hello.html so if you've
never seen raw html it's the fundamental
language of the web and this is the sort
of thing that you ought to do if you're
writing html for the first time so it
says beginning of html page end of html
page and in the middle you basically say
hello to newton
and so this file is it's placed in just
the right location
lets you open up a web browser
and on that web browser here i'm just
going to localhost this isn't actually
live out on the web but you get the idea
and we can say hello newton
now what's really happening here is that
your web browser is sending a request to
the web server that looks in just the
right place it finds just the right file
the information in that file is
transmitted to your web browser and your
web browser knows how to render this
html in sort of a user-friendly way
that's all there is to it and and that's
the basic building block beyond
everything that we're going to do now
you visit lots of web pages today and
there's bells and whistles and things
look fantastic but fundamentally that's
just
juice on top of a very simple technology
so let's just deal with the simple stuff
first and then maybe we can trust that
you can figure out other stuff down the
road
so a next step up from that is to
get out of this documents folder and
go into this folder cgi executable it's
on a linux system that was that would be
called the cgi bin
it's a different location for
a different purpose but the end result
is going to be very similar so i want to
look at this
food.cgi
thing
this is actually a perl script
you could do the same thing in different
languages you might use php you might
use python
windows probably has something but i
don't know what it is and don't really
care you see i have some certain biases
and i'm not shy about sharing them so
this little perl script
says
really hello world it's the same sort of
thing but you're actually looking at a
script in a language the language is
perl and the perl script is actually of
writing
html
this is essentially the same sort of
html thing i just haven't bolded the
word world say or change world to newton
and so we can go through a very similar
exercise here
so instead of looking at hello.html
directly i'm on my local host i say i'm
in i want to go to cgi bin i happen to
know that there's this program here
called foo dot cgi and i can run it in
the browser but before i do that i'm
going to go back here
and type perl
foo dot cgi
so from the command line i can actually
run this perl script using the perl
interpreter and all it does is print out
the html code and i'm saying code
because html stands for hypertext markup
language so this document that you're
seeing on the web is really the result
of writing something like code following
the rules of a language you might not
think of it like a language but i think
it's fair to call one
so we're going to go back here now and
we have the cgi bin slash
foo.cgi
and you get exactly the same thing
but what's happening now is a little bit
different you're sending a request to
the web server the web server receives
the request
it's going now into the cgi bin it's
finding a script written in this
language called perl it's running the
perl script which is writing html code
that's being sent to the browser and
rendered in your browser
now
that may be painfully obvious to half of
you and that's that's fine if it is but
it's probably not obvious to a couple of
you um that being able to author code in
one language by using another language
is incredibly useful it's a little bit
of an abstraction but trust me it's
extremely useful and that one simple
example is underneath almost everything
else that we're going to talk about
tonight so i thought it was worth saying
hello world in this really
old-fashioned circa 1990
i won't even say
technology
okay so we start out with html we
introduce cgi scripting cgi scripting is
behind a lot of
forms say that you encounter on the web
you visit a web page it says
uh you know type in this type in that
maybe choose something and it collects
those results it actually typically
sends those results to a different cgi
script that receives that information
and does something fancy and we'll
actually see examples of that later on
with more interesting examples but this
basic technology has been around for
you know probably more than 20 years at
this point i must apologize i don't
actually know what a fair starting date
would be but this is not new technology
and yet it's really the same sort of
thing that we're going to be dealing
with with the more advanced examples
later
so let me pause there any questions
yeah
cgi a common gateway interface sorry
good question others
okay so let's move on
um
i'm actually going to start with um
simon urbanix package fast r web
and i'm going to start by saying hello
world and then i'll give you a couple
more interesting examples
and if you'll bear with me for a second
hello world i promised
exactly the same example done in a
different way so look at this for a
second i assume everyone here is
familiar with at least a little bit of r
so
this is our code
this file contains the definition of a
function that function needs to be
called run in lowercase letters
it can have arguments this particular
function just uses dot dot
the body of the function in this case
contains
two function calls
you're probably not familiar with either
of them unless you've seen science past
our web package before
so fast our web includes a very short
list of functions that support
everything that we're going to do
and done is probably fairly obvious
out basically says um
send this result out in a very specific
way and frankly that specific way is
compatible with html because everything
that we're doing here we're talking
about delivering things on the web so
simon is taking care of a lot of
business for us but what's interesting
here is that just as with cgi scripting
with pearl
we're now able to use cgi scripting with
r which is great for those of us who
really like r and maybe use pearl but
rather not
or people who realize that you can do a
lot of statistics and cool stuff in r
that would be really tedious and plural
might be possible that's sort of painful
in python you know you can go down the
list
um
so that may or may not be true depending
on what you're trying to do in python
but as a general rule i think that
you'll have more tools easily at your
fingertips using r
so
just as we did before the script needs
to be in just the right place this is
actually running off the web server up
at yale
but if i uh go over to my browser
and go up to
euler. instead
okay it reloaded that's really small i
apologize but up in the url
euler.stat.yale.edu is the server up at
yale slash cgi bin is the right place to
put stuff like this after the cgi bin
there's a capital r
that looks like a folder
it's actually an executable provided by
simon then processes everything
following the r
so here's what's happening
apache knows that
simon has r serve and faststar web
installed on this particular computer
receives a request when it receives that
request it uses rservenfastr web to go
off
look at that file that file contains the
function run
needs to
it takes that function it actually runs
it it does whatever is in the file
whatever is in that file is running our
code
that is then authoring html code that's
sent to the browser and you just your
browser says hello world
so exactly the same thing is
happened previously using the perl
example except now we're using the r
language
um it's got configuration options so you
can tell fast our web
when it's
launched initially on the server to load
up certain certain packages
so that when a visitor arrives at the
site r is already running in the
background it's already loaded those
packages and might already have done a
little bit of work to prepare some data
for for some query that might be
expecting
so the uh the performance of faster web
is really very impressive there's not a
whole lot of a lag between the time that
the um request hits the web server and
the time that your result comes back to
the user
okay so if you can
say hello world you can do almost
anything and by that i really mean that
that function it's an
r function you can take everything you
know about r and put it in a function
like that for a certain purpose
so let's take a small step forward
instead of instead of just saying hello
world whoops that didn't work
spoiler.stat
yep
cgi bin our name
i believe example1.png
okay there's a plot
and i might even be able to say
actually i'm not sure if i can do that
yet so i'll stick with the plot
there's a plot
it's basically a plot of an r norm of
something against an r norm of something
i think i don't really remember maybe we
should look at the file and find out
so if i look at um
example1.png.r again a single function
called run
um
let's see that's there's just a dot dot
so i thought there might be an argument
passed to that function and i was
mistaken i i thought there was maybe
that's example two
again there's a couple of new things
here but there's really not that much
infesta web that you need to know about
obviously it's really handy to be able
to send graphics out on the web in order
to be able to
render an r graphic on the web you need
to use fastar web to declare that it's
about to produce a plot you use the
function web plot to do that then you do
whatever r code you want to do to
generate the plot
and then by just typing p it's rendered
here i'm not quite sure why there isn't
a done on the end i don't know if that
was my omission or maybe that was an
example that came from simon's i don't
see any reason we couldn't put done
there
but again you know how to use r you can
take everything you know how to do and
then render the results on the web so
this is maybe example one of them
you can see i've got a lot of examples
of that but
i don't see example two
that's too bad
let's skip it and move on we have a lot
to cover you've seen example one i want
to show you a more interesting example
now and make an argument that you can
really leverage this very simple
technology to do quite a bit a project
i've been involved with over the last
couple of years is the environmental
performance index
it's a project that's um
that seeks any way to try to rank
countries based on different aspects of
their environmental performance
and so this is a website that was mostly
produced by some professional graphics
artists
but underneath we have something called
a data explorer we can go to say a table
of main results
and here's the first example
when you visit this page
the nice graphics up at top you know
that's a that's not me i don't do stuff
like that right i
couldn't produce something pretty like
that if i needed to so you have a
professional do something like that and
then on a web page like this you
basically have a big empty box that big
empty box if you've done anything with
web programming is called an iframe
in that iframe
it's referencing
a script that's on the server in the
department of statistics in the same
folder where we were just operating
so someone visits this page the iframe
sends a query to the stat department
server
calling a script it's a script that i
wrote entirely in r
that's probably using
the google vis package to generate this
table of results
the results um are presented and
immediately available to my script
because the package is loaded up ahead
of time at start time if you haven't
seen google vis before it's really
pretty cool you can produce a table like
this and just by clicking on the uh that
column headers it sorts interactively
this is not a static table this actually
has a little bit of interactivity that
you you may not have seen before you can
sort
in reverse order
i've also
linked say
the entries in the table something
called a country profile
and again this is the same idea when you
visit this page
you can see up in the url
there's actually an extra option here so
this is passing an argument to the cgi
script saying i want to know about the
united states
so that argument is passed to my script
it's an r script
the r script takes the argument that
says i want to learn about the usa
and the script produces everything
basically in the lower part of this
table this is using base grid graphics a
wonderful package from paul morell down
in new zealand if you're designing your
own customized displays this is really
the way to do it lots of standard
displays you can either use base
graphics or something like ggplot that's
great but you can't produce a plot like
that
using a standard plot command you really
have to go in and put every rectangle
and every number in exactly the right
place using exactly the right color
shading
and all that code is inside a function
called run
sitting over there on the web server
and so
everything that i did down below which
by the way includes some uh like a k
nearest neighbor calculation to identify
countries with similar levels of
performance
but that's the sort of thing you do in r
i want to do k nearest neighboring arm
no problem boom got it i want to do
k-means clustering in r it's ready to go
want to do a linear model that's fine
all that can be done so quickly and
easily in r and now all of that ability
is at your fingertips
just waiting to be rendered on the web
when you get a request
so i realize the um
that it's a little bit small but part of
this url says
probably country profiles
i happen to know that that's wrong so
let me just look at this
i would say
cpmain.r
sounds more like the script that's
rendering this
there we go
it's a single r script the r script
contains a single function that function
has to be run in lowercase letters you
can see with this example i now have
some arguments to the function with
default values so if you visit this page
you're going to get switzerland by
default because they came out at the top
of this this index
but if options are passed to this
function
the options are processed below
i'm not going to really look at any of
this code just to show you that
everything here is r code
in fact it's fairly standard r code
there's a lot of it i don't even
remember how many lines there are
but this is all stuff that you can do if
you work in r
all simon is doing all simon is doing
simon is doing wonderful things to then
allow you to take everything you already
know how to do and deliver it on the web
there's some extras that you might need
to know about it's helpful to know
something about cascading style sheets
css
just so the fonts maybe are consistent
with the look and feel that you want on
the site and you can go as deeply into
that sort of thing as you want and it's
all again provided by the infrastructure
here of simon's uh simon's package
let me pause there
questions on that yes
so on your server there what what did
what someone need to do to actually set
up fast
to enable the server yeah that's a great
question suppose you wanted to use
fastairweb
i'm just curious
yep right there so it used to be around
four or five i guess it got bumped down
to six or seven i have a blog that i
basically never use
but once in a while i post things that
might be useful and one of the entries
that i thought might be useful was a
how-to about setting up faststar web
there's actually a set of steps that
almost certainly will work on a on a
linux box it might actually be a little
out of date i think that he's improved
his install script
so that if you actually go on his web
there's step-by-step instructions it is
a two-step process you need to first of
all have a machine running a web server
that i think needs to be um a unix web
server i don't think he supports windows
you need to install rserv and then fast
r web move something into just the right
place where these instructions and
probably simon's will will help you out
um it's it's not really too bad
yeah simon also took quite a bit of time
thinking about some security concerns
that people might reasonably have with
cgi scripting
and
partly because he was doing this down
for for use at a t
and they actually care quite a bit about
security so
yes
you use fast star web as a compiler so
what you do is you
compile a static html web page
store it and then redisplay it on a
server that does not have power running
can you do that
i don't see any reason you would
um you would need to do that no because
a lot of a lot of the commercial servers
do not have r one of them understood you
really can't run r on them right but i'd
like to be able to take some graphics
yeah generated on a server that does
have r yeah so i i've actually done that
before i just write the the r script to
do that just author in our script to
produce
an html page and embed it in that page
would be links to whatever graphics you
want
you could probably do that can i use
faster web as uh
as the methodology for me to generate
that as opposed to otherwise i'm just
writing an r code
with no advantage at all on this
superior package
you know it might save you a little bit
of time i actually don't think we'd save
you as much time as you think it might
save you um you could do that i believe
because everything that fast our web
generates
um
produces a temporary copy
in a directory that's called
temp
and so you might be able to
produce a series of queries uh
to the web pages that you want to
generate and then pick them up in temp
maybe it's a little bit of a hack
again i wouldn't be recommending that
but
buyer viewer yes
that's true you don't need to go through
anything
data set that's on the server already
uh
i am working with dataset i have put on
the server already a convenient way to
do that is just to dump your datasets
into a package and when you
fire up our server and faster web on the
server those are loaded automatically so
they're ready to go in the session
i'll tell you what that's it's a great
question because maybe it's a good segue
to fast start web
i won't show an example of this but
excuse me a secret shiny
shiny actually has the ability to handle
uploads and downloads
quickly and easily that are probably
better suited to that purpose
i think if simon were here
he'd say oh china is pretty cool but i
can do everything shiny can do within
vancouver web
um
i think he's he's probably either right
or very close to being right but from
experience i'd say that that's going to
rely on your having a level of expertise
it's probably
unrealistic it's certainly unrealistic
for me
i'm sure simon can do it but very few of
us are as good as sort of like
scientists
and for the shining through giving you
the ability to do some things that are
far more advanced without the same level
of knowledge that would be required if
you were using faster web
so
the answer is i'm really glad that i
have both tools i'm a big fan of star
web
but chinese is really cool and a lot of
things are much easier and shiny than
ever
other questions
i have questions here
have you heard something called the r
notebook
the r notebook i have not uh
no okay uh there's this thing in the
part down below
here
that way they know what you're asking
hello
there's this thing the ipod
which python people
generally know about basically it's
it's it's kind of like python embedded
in a mathematical interface so it's a um
basically similar kinds of data
exploration and visualization um
close
that closely shadows the way the python
interpreter
normally works so um
i was literally just i wasn't keeping
tabs on that i had heard about a
developmental community for that i
wasn't keeping close tabs on it i
literally just had someone do a search
back there
and just in the past few weeks
apparently october there is
an initial release of something called
the our notebook
so what i was going to ask was you know
what the art of looking how it compares
but maybe we can just
you know that's a tip for you maybe the
next time you give us a talk yeah that's
carlos schneider from atg livestock's
assignment
and is that renamed from the things that
he presented last year yeah yeah okay
so he presented something similar to
last year here
he called it
he called our club last year something
else had that name
right so it's not the art notebook it's
very different than what jay is showing
this more like an end user the article
books that we use in our program would
go in there write code and get the
result generated right on the page and
write more code get the result generated
it is like
a very different pass-through web but
it's being created by the guy who sits
next to simon att labs carlos
scheidinger
sure
carlos are you here
no
um he did speak back in
uh uh october of last year i believe
sometime last year there might be a
video there might be slides available
from him if not it is really cool it's
not quite what the pi python notebook is
yet but it's two weeks old it will be
getting there i think
it's great having people in the audience
who are
willing and able to answer questions
that i can't answer so keep asking me
questions and someone will know the
answer
so let's switch now to uh to shiny
and i'm actually going to introduce this
by by talking a little bit about shiny
helper
which i think is maybe in an easier way
to get into shiny the very first time
i've continued using it a little bit
myself but
i i think that maybe a couple people
have found that it's a useful way to get
started and then after you sort of get
it
you might not need to use it again so
i'm not sure where that places it on the
list of things that are broadly useful
but
take a look and at least it's up on
github it's freely available most of the
examples that i do are either included
directly with shiny helper or are up on
the web someplace
so let me just go go right into it
everything's up on github there's
instructions for actually getting it
there's a clever way to get it it makes
use of dev tools
um but
let's see
if i'm over here in r i've got a script
that i prepared is the font big enough
in the back we okay yeah
i'm gonna load shiny helper
and let's say hello world i think that's
really the right place to start once
again
and so here's a little bit of code it
even fits on the screen
so
how many of you heard of package
skeleton
a couple hands so if you're interested
in writing your own r package package
skeleton is a great place to start start
a fresh r session
create objects functions anything like
that in the r section in the r session
and then run package skeleton it takes
everything basically from your current
session or a list of things that you
want and puts them basically in a
package for you
along with
some help pages various things there's
probably clever ways to do it but it's
basically the right place to start by
writing packages i think
and then you can edit those
those files following the rules from
arcore and cram and you get an r package
so i created
shiny skeleton
as basically a way of giving you an
empty shiny app
and then we're going to add
functionality to that shiny app using
functions that are merely convenience
functions
so all i've really done here is is
create a set of functions such as
header panel add
and so the dirty little secret is that
there's a function called header panel
inside of shiny
and so i put the name add after it and
i'm writing the function for you
essentially i'm writing a function call
for you that's consistent with the
syntax of shiny
slider input at slider input is actually
something that you would need to make
use of in shiny
and i'm creating an extra level of
abstraction here that is authoring shiny
code for you
so china itself is written in r
so i'm writing r code but i'm writing r
code that's consistent with the design
of shiny and as we look at this example
you'll see that although it looks like
our code and frankly it is our code
there's some oddities to the way i think
um that a shiny app looks like
that that makes it difficult to get into
the very first time after you're used to
it it's a different matter but my hope
is that this is a useful way to get you
started so as you as you might guess
here slider input add is saying i want
to create this application and on the
application i want to have a slider and
let people choose the sample size it'll
go from 100 to 500 with a default value
of 100 and i'm going to associate
with the number chosen by the user
this
letter n the symbol n
which is then available to you is
input dollar sign n
and so what you're doing here with plot
output add
is giving yourself a chance to write our
code to do something that you'd like to
do
and that our code here is just being
presented as a string
and that code is being injected for you
into the app in just the right way
so that it provides interactivity
between the slider and the plot that's
being rendered
and so you don't have to worry about all
the things you need to keep track of in
shiny to pull this off
this sequence of commands right here
is sufficient to create this shiny app
so i'll copy and i guess i can just hit
run
okay
and run app hello shiny so i'm in my r
session now
in this particular example i'm just
running it locally on my computer
but if you were actually running shiny
server on a web server some place this
would be available over the web to
someone who points their browser into in
just the right location
so run app shiny hello shiny is
sufficient here
it automatically launches the browser in
the browser you have a slider and then
to the right you have a histogram of in
this case 100 random normal observations
and if i change that 100 to
500 there's this immediate interactivity
between the user input and the plot
that's being rendered it's basically
re-running the code regenerating the
plot and rendering it in the browser
so it's not quite hello world but it's
not too far beyond hello world
it's an image
yeah sorry
yeah thanks
it's a png
thank you
other questions
okay let's look at what this app looks
like there's actually not a whole lot to
it
so i am
desktop dropbox talks
intro shiny
okay
um when we
ran that little block of code and that
little block of code is actually up on
uh github
i didn't show you but it actually
created this thing right here hello
shiny which is a folder we go into the
folder
there's two files and every shiny app
has at least these two things
server.r and ui.r ui is for user
interface server is self-explanatory if
we look at
ui.r
so here i'm requiring shiny helper just
because there's some some juice to some
of the apps that i need extra functions
for
shiny ui this is the shiny user
interface construction
the the standard page that's in most of
the examples you'll find is this thing
called a page with a sidebar so i have
the sidebar on the left where those user
inputs and then i have the area on the
right where stuff is displayed
broadly
i have a title essentially
in the sidebar panel right now all i
have is that single slider input and you
can see how everything there probably
occurs from corresponds pretty directly
to what you saw in the function call
just a few minutes earlier
scroll down to the main panel the main
panel is basically saying aha there's
going to be a plot
and
the plot is
my plot
and the dirty details about my plot are
over in server.r
that's it that's the end of this file
now you can see that this is our code
but there's something a little bit odd
here if you're used to doing data
analysis you're used to loading up a
data set and looking at the head of the
data set checking the dimension maybe do
a summary of some of the variables this
is a little bit odd what do we have here
we're loading a package
and then that first line that's a
function call
okay and then
the first argument to this function call
is another function call
and let's see this page with sidebar
function call
the first argument to that is a function
call header panel and then see that
comma
that comma is after the first argument
to the function page with sidebar
the second argument
sidebar panel
that's another function call
and you
you look at this for a while and then
you look at server.r and it's easy to
lose track of
whether you're writing our code that's
actually part of a function call or
whether you're writing r code that's
actually our code that you're used to
seeing if you're doing data analysis so
the first time you look at some of these
examples it really is a little bit odd
my hope is that
by creating an app that's actually
useful with very little pain with shiny
helper you then can look at an example
of working on shiny code and then modify
it and learn more about shiny on your
own that was my opinion
so let's go look at server.r
server. is even shorter
again just requiring a package shiny
server again that's a function call
its first argument is oh boy
its first argument is
not a function call it is a function
call but it's really defining a function
it's defining a function that has input
and output and then here's the body of
the function
and the body of the function contains
a funny assignment we're assigning
something to output my plot remember my
plot you saw it a second ago over in
ui.r
that's the same my plot
we're using a function render plots
provided by shiny
for
unsurprisingly rendering a plot
and here's the code that you provided to
me in shiny helper so all shiny helpers
really
done is insulate you from having to
figure out exactly how to author this
shiny app in just the right way the
first time after you get the hang of it
you can probably do it on your own
so let's look at a more interesting
example now
i'll zip back over here to
my script
this demo is actually included with
shiny helper so if you get shiny helper
from
github you'll be able to do exactly this
um
i'll do this one line at a time oh
before i do that
you can see down in the console it says
listening on port 8100
8100 is the port that shiny is using to
do this and it's still listening so over
in my browser we still have that
little histogram app running and because
that's running my r console is frozen so
r is actually supporting that
application right now and i can't work
interactively here in our studio if i
hit the stop button it gets me out of
that now i can proceed to the next app
so the demo is included with shiny
helper and make this
bigger
maybe
hit return to start go ahead
so when you run this demo you can go and
look through this you can see the
example is a little bit more involved
most of it you saw before now you can
see that
my plot is a much more involved plot but
the same ideas apply i'm now going to be
able to provide say a range of years
that information from the user will be
available to me in input year range
so there's just a few things that you
need to know when you're writing your
code but most of this is standard based
graphics stuff
and it produces the following app
so this again is based on that epi
project that
i mentioned a second ago
i don't know why that didn't run run app
api
2012.
there we go
okay very simple app this is from the
last iteration of the epi
we can choose a country and again this
is all interactive so
you choose a country and all the data is
immediately available it's going through
and just based on inputs provided by the
user
it's choosing to display
different information as appropriate so
this is a time series plot if i'm
unhappy with the range of the plot
i can shorten the range so here it
starts at 2002 i can introduce some data
from other countries for the purpose of
making a
some sort of comparison that's
interesting
so this is close to something that i'm
actually using on a day-to-day basis
with the epi team
i'm the only one who really writes our
code in any serious way on the team so i
can put together a shiny app like this i
throw it up on the web and they can
quickly and easily start browsing the
you know the current draft results of
the epi without needing to know anything
about r
it's limited to what i'm choosing to
render to them in an app
but it really is miles ahead of what
they'd be able to do on their own
otherwise
so once again let me pause there are
there some questions about this example
yes what would an equivalent look like
in fast armor
let's just talk about a simpler example
a drop down
so if you know a little bit about basic
html
html provides a support for forms
a form is basically
a url to a cgi script
and then
information in this case country names
and maybe values associated with those
country names are actually in the html
code in a very specific format so if you
know a little bit about html you could
actually author the html code yourself
to produce a drop down and i actually
did that in the um in the epi project
using faster web so i authored the
correct html code to render a drop down
associated with that drop down in a form
another
faster web script that would receive the
information and um and generate the
output properly so you could actually do
that drop down invest our web it would
be like reloading a page and on that new
page you'd see the new plot it wouldn't
be quite as seamless as this
and a lot more work
it would actually force you to know a
little bit more about html forms good
question others
yes
i don't think so because you have to
have a way of having
a chinese server running up on github
if not i think they're still working on
a business model for
um what they're going to charge for
versus what they're going to provide for
maybe developers
like you
expensive
other questions
let me show i guess what is it what is
that data getting loaded from and is it
accessible to a different user ah
so
yeah that's a good question um
if i go back into rstudio
uh
really not very good with this
in fact i didn't even want to be there
there's the code for the plot and then
right there there's a there's a function
that i wrote called inject data
so when you're writing an app and you
want a certain data object to be
available to the app
um
it's a little bit of a kludge but i
that's part of what shiny helper is
doing for you
it's giving you a mechanism for
making data objects available to the app
and my short name for that was inject
data
if you want to see what inject data
actually does you could go look at the
app that's produced
and look at the shiny code that
obviously has to do with that object so
you have a sense of what's going on
we could do that very quickly
if i go back and go into let's see epi
2012 is the um the folder that was just
created if we you can see that x dot r
data
i put that in the right place and then
if we look in say server.r
i'm just loading that
up front um and then i can actually make
use of it
down here and doing the plot you can see
for instance right there x dollar sign
iso
so that's coming from the object x so
that's one of the things that
shiny helper is doing for you so you
don't need to figure out how to do it
the first time
good other questions
let me zip
back into here take a quick look
okay
as i said still running i have to stop
it
so this is an app again
a basic version of this app was produced
using shiny helper
and so that basically did the job
but shiny has a feature to provide
conditional
user input and by conditional user input
i mean that the user might be faced with
some options over here in this case
select plot type united states or select
individual states
this is an example of a conditional user
input where if you go down and select
individual states the user is then
presented with a different set of
options to choose from
seems like a very simple thing something
that obviously you'd want to do
and it's not that hard using shiny
and i just wanted to have one example of
doing that
so we by default are focusing on
connecticut but again the same principle
applies as you go through and the user
provides different types of input the um
the plot is immediately responding so
once again you have this interplay
between whatever the user is providing
for the input and the resulting plot
this is just using the maps package
i put this together because i had to
give a talk at the census bureau and i
figured i'd better use their data
okay
so we're pretty close to eight right now
so i think what i'd like to do is
leave it right there for now you want me
to talk a little bit more
i actually prefer to open the questions
right now and if there really aren't any
i probably have i actually i do have one
more example i'd like to do but a
question in the back
yeah good good question in fact i have
two things i want to show you and
the one that i forgot relates exactly to
that question
um
so if you're writing down urls and i
apologize this is small but um
www.stat.yale.edu
slash tilda j j ay which you have to
spell properly
i'm getting old
j
okay
so there's my uh home page i'm easy to
google
if you take that url and on the end add
capital e c
e c is probably for
is it elastic cloud
yeah so whatever it is
the amazon thingy that's sort of cool
we put some instructions up here on what
you would actually have to do
to create a node up on the amazon cloud
and then you want to be able to install
r you want to be able to install fast r
web and you want to be able to install a
web server obviously and shiny server
so
if you're really interested in this you
probably want to know about this
because this is a set of scripts that
will do all of that for you so you don't
have to figure it out
and if you can do it up on amazon you
can probably figure out how to do it on
your own web server
now the reason i needed to do that
obviously i wanted you to know about it
but i needed to grab this url right here
because it's not something anyone would
remember
and so we're visiting my node up on the
amazon server and i happen to remember
that
is the port
that's used by shiny
and so on port 3838 of this obscure
little dinky box running up on amazon's
ec2
we have a couple of examples that you've
seen some of these already
but you also have a folder called
examples
in that folder of examples is the set of
examples that's provided by the shiny
folks to do
a great list of basic things that almost
everyone would want to do with a shiny
app and i believe one of those is upload
and one of them is download
and so although i have not written a
shiny app to do that and i'm not
supporting that currently in shiny
helper it wouldn't be that hard to add
that functionality in but in terms of
what you're asking i'd say the thing to
do is to get used to shiny with some
basic examples and then when you want to
learn about say shiny upload
go here and here's an example of a shiny
app that supports that upload and the
code to do this is up on
i'm pretty sure it's up on github from
our studio
so i didn't quite show you how to do it
but that's how you would find out how to
do it and i'll want to do it myself
fairly soon
other questions
yeah so my server is about to expire
anyway i got sort of a year of this
instance running up there and
so yeah it's
you can just turn it off it's no big
deal
this is a good place to play with things
so you don't do something that you don't
want to on your your production box
yes so you've shown some examples that
you said are like pretty basic can you
show us something that's really cool
yeah let me show you something oh that i
did no i can't drink it
there you go let me show you that that's
a great request
um
other
shiny leaflet
so
this is not my example which is probably
why it's really cool
um browser
so uh this is joe cheng basically wrote
shiny so he's the guy this example is up
on the web and there's probably a link
um
there's
did i have that
here
oh yeah good thank you
glimmer
okay now i always have trouble when i do
this demo um running my own computer and
maybe you'll see why in a second
this is a really cool example i think
um you actually have some interactivity
with the plot up top we'll be able to
zoom in we'll be able to zoom out
as you're zooming in and out and this is
powered by leaflet with maps by macbox
if that means anything to anyone that's
how we do it
as you zoom in and out or re-center
in the plot at the top it keeps track of
the latitude and longitude of the
of the map that's being displayed and it
keeps track of the center of the map
passes that information down below so
this is actually a form of user input
you have interactivity with a plot up at
the top and that's just another form of
user input much like choosing a year or
choosing something here
so now we have user input down here we
have user input up there and that's also
a display
and we've got plots that update based on
what part of the country you're looking
at
so now let me ruin it all by messing up
the demonstration but in theory that's
what you're supposed to be able to do
so i'll try the simple one first i'll
zoom in
there we go
so as i zoom in you can see there's very
faint you can't see but there are very
faint green circles up in the top that
are the cities that are identified
if we go down here in the bottom
it says the map is centered at and it
gives you those coordinates and it says
the top 100 out of 7830
visible cities are being displayed
visible cities appear in this list down
below total population of visible cities
so everything down here has adapted to
the particular zoom
that you've achieved up in the top and
so we can drag this over and as you drag
that the information down below is being
updated
okay so that's
i don't know if it's a whole lot cooler
but it certainly is a whole lot more
professional than my examples is that
okay
yeah
um and so you probably saw a second ago
i was actually at joe's github site that
has this example on it so you can
download all this code
i've gotten it to run on my laptop i've
never spent a whole lot of time actually
looking at the code behind the scenes to
see how he integrated it with leaflet
and mapbox but it's all open source it's
all out there
other questions
i think i almost did it
45 minutes
i think that's it then i'd be happy to
talk to anyone afterwards if you have
specific questions
about anything
i have one question about the master's
program
happy to talk about that
fantasy football i can talk about that
thank you all for coming